y
bueno realmente nunca pensé y me imaginé
que podría transformar vidas voy a
contar la historia de mi vida
rápidamente y justamente en un momento
donde eso no estaba en mi cabeza no
sabía en ese momento que iba a pasar y
que iba a transcurrir en mi vida para
empezar a tener algunas evidencias y
hechos que demuestran que fue
transformando o ayudando o colaborando
transformar vidas esta historia arranca
cuando estaba estudiando la carrera
lista de sistemas y el estudio fue algo
elegido algo que me gustaba eran las
alternativas que había evaluado en su
momento cuando decidí la carrera
desde ese momento empecé a proyectar qué
iba a pasar cuando terminara de estudiar
y como toda persona que eligió una
carrera y empezó a definir oa planificar
qué quería hacer yo quería terminar
empezar a trabajar en una empresa de
tecnología o en algún área de sistemas
de alguna empresa de la región era ese
ideal que tenía y que de alguna manera
media fijado y justamente pasó eso
termine empezó a trabajar inmediatamente
en diferentes posiciones dentro de los
sistemas estoy creciendo aprendiendo y
desarrollando me dentro de la empresa
trabajé varios años
crecí aprendí como dije recién llegó un
momento donde todo lo que había pensado
se había cumplido forme una familia
tenía un puesto laboral tenía un buen
sueldo estaba cumpliendo mi plan pero
algo me empezó a picar internamente el
bichito que me picaba en ese momento me
decía que esto lo que realmente quería
hacer el resto de tu vida
esto es lo que proyectas te acerques a
ver un dilema mi cabeza
y en mi corazón que decía que tenía que
cambiar veía un techo veía que ese
momento tenía que pasar otra historia
y bueno ahí recurrir algo que yo llamo
soporte técnico no por la profesión sino
porque realmente lo comparo a una idea
de soporte técnico cuando lo necesita el
soporte técnico salud que ustedes
necesitan piden o van a buscar cuando
tienen un problema cuando tiene alguna
duda cuando tienen alguna inquietud y no
saben cómo responderla
y justamente soporte técnico en ese
momento fue mi familia mi familia me
ayudó y me contuvo a que esa decisión
que era difícil porque culturalmente
había sido preparado para eso tenía que
cambiar
como dije recién era el sueño que me
había imaginado mis papás me estaban
contentos por lo que hacía y de alguna
manera está demostrando que lo que había
planificado se cumplía pero no era lo
que quería y mi familia fue el artífice
y fue parte y fue fundamental en la
decisión de cambio ya había decidido
tomar otro camino pero además de mi
familia y lo importante que fue en esa
decisión y lo sigue siendo apareció otro
factor importante que yo lo llamo mi
primer socio ideal
ese socio ideal es un amigo es leandro
estudiamos juntos nos conocimos en
realidad cursando la carrera
terminamos estudiar los dos seguimos
caminos profesionales distintos y
justamente como yo tenía ese ruido en la
cabeza leandro también tenía un ruido en
la cabeza haciendo lo que estaba
haciendo
un día nos encontramos en unas
vacaciones que estábamos juntos
compartimos con la familia y me sé que
me diste a laborar conmigo
y elaborar conmigo era sumarme un
emprendimiento que eran dos o tres
desarrolladores del software en rafaela
donde nacimos donde nos criamos donde
crecimos justamente lo que necesitaba
era que lo ayude a hacer crecer el
emprendimiento y yo por otro lado estaba
viendo que quería hacer otra cosa
entonces es como que en ese momento
juntamos las ideas nos asociamos y
empezamos a caminar juntos en esta dupla
de socios
yo soy batman por las dudas antes que
hagan alguna comparación él no está acá
y no puede decir nada pero yo me tomo la
atribución de decir que soy el
superhéroe y él me acompaña pero bueno
este empezamos a transitar el camino del
emprendimiento
de la idea del emprendimiento pero que
todavía la decisión no estaba todo
tomada
o sea yo tenía que decidir y ese día fue
el que tome la decisión yo les damos día
a la independencia lo que ven ahí no es
la casita de tucumán
es una casa donde arrancamos con leo con
los dos o tres tres eran programadores
esa casa de una foto actual en la ciudad
rafael a ahí arrancamos tampoco es un
garaje porque quiero que asocien la
tecnología con el garaje y todas las
empresas tecnologías nacen en un garage
bueno esta casa no tenía ganas
habilitado usaba un vecino en realidad
garage nosotros usamos la parte
habitable de habitaciones este pero
bueno ahí arrancamos y comenzamos esta
idea de crecer juntos de empezar a
transformar nuestras vidas transformar
la vida de la gente con la cual en ese
momento estábamos trabajando y la
realidad que fuimos creciendo y fuimos
creciendo muy rápido
rápido para lo que es una pyme para lo
que es un equipo de trabajo en una
ciudad como rafaela con todos los
desafíos que implica estar en un mercado
muy chico pero siempre con la visión de
no tener clientes o no rafaela sino de
tener clientes en argentina tener
clientes en el exterior de crecer
y ese crecimiento como dije fue bastante
rápido exponencial año año llegamos a
tener 130 colaboradores en nuestro
emprendimiento clientes de todo tipo
oficinas en rafaela oficinas en santafé
oficinas en paraná incorporamos un
tercer socio del emprendimiento crecimos
y nos convertimos en una de las empresas
de software más importantes de la
provincia
ese equipo que logramos armar
estaba formado por personas que
arrancaron con nosotros algunos y otros
que fuimos sumando dentro de ese dentro
de esa historia de emprendimiento y yo
destacó justamente mucho el tema del
equipo
como verán me gusta el cine y pongo
algunas imágenes que tienen que tienen
relación con lo que les quiero
transmitir en el señor de los anillos'
la comunidad del anillo
es una comunidad formada por distintos
personajes tampoco soy ninguno de los
que está ahí por las dudas claro este
porque estos personajes que tenía un
objetivo común encontrar el anillo
tenían un objetivo que perseguían todos
esos miembros del equipo
independientemente del mundo donde
estuvieran independientemente de la
situación en la que tuvieran enfrente
independientemente las dificultades
todos seguíamos el mismo objetivo el
objetivo era crecer desarrollarnos hacer
lo que nos gustaba
generar una transformación en la vida de
las personas de ese equipo y de las
personas que rodeaban ese equipo y por
supuesto de la comunidad la comunidad
siempre nos dio la posibilidad de hacer
lo que nos gustaba y nosotros alguna
manera sentíamos que teníamos que
devolverlo y empezamos a notarlo con los
socios empezamos a notar que la gente
que había nacido con nosotros que había
acompañado este proceso ya tenía familia
ya tenía hijos
y se quedaban en el lugar donde habían
nacido siempre pusimos sobre la mesa
como estrategia de crecimiento el
emprendimiento desarrollar la zona a
desarrollar la ciudad hacer dar
oportunidad que la gente pueda tener
trabajo de calidad al mismo nivel que
cualquier equipo de desarrollo de
software y equipo de tecnología a nivel
mundial con proyectos muy desafiantes y
eso lo empezamos a apartar y ver con mis
socios usted dirán bueno genial nosotros
estamos contentos felices pero empezamos
a pensar con nuestros socios donde
queríamos estar dentro de un tiempo y
vuelvo algo que me pasó cuando decidí
armar el emprendimiento o sea había
logrado el objetivo después de tanto
tiempo de ver construir una empresa de
que sea exitosa de dar trabajo a la
gente estamos contentos y entusiasmado
con lo que hacíamos pero empezamos a ver
cuál es la historia más adelante
empezamos a planificar más adelante y
empezamos a ver
que el crecimiento ya no dependía sólo
de nosotros el mundo cambio los mercados
cambiaron la competencia cambió la
tecnología evolucionó fuertemente
entonces empezamos a ver que necesitamos
algún acompañamiento adicional para
poder seguir creciendo
y ese acompañamiento adicional
yo le llamo nuestro socio ideal número 2
y busco el concepto ideal porque en
realidad no es que ese socio aparece el
día de un día para la noche o que
aparece instantáneamente o por arte de
magia uno va generando procesos en la
vida y uno va trabajando y va
evolucionando y los momentos siempre
llegan los momentos siempre llegan
cuando tienen que llegar ese socio es un
socio que nos dio la posibilidad de
volar de crecer de mirar de otra manera
a nuestro futuro de trascender más allá
de lo que hemos trascendido con nuestro
emprendimiento ese socio es actualmente
la empresa en la cual trabajó era un
cliente nuestro de la compañía de la
empresa de software este y básicamente
lo que necesitaba ese cliente era crecer
en equipos de tecnología en el interior
del país y no sólo lo que necesitamos en
una empresa que nos haga crecer que nos
lleve para arriba que nos haga cumplir
los sueños que con nuestros socios
estábamos teniendo en la cabeza y
empezamos a imaginarnos
es ese momento es un momento tan
decisivo para nosotros como lo fue el
momento en el cual decidí dejar de
trabajar y empezar el emprendimiento si
nosotros tomamos la decisión de vender
la empresa
a una empresa que nos permitiera
mantener la esencia mantén el mismo
espíritu con el cual habíamos formado el
emprendimiento y con el cual yo me había
formado y trabajado toda mi vida seguir
haciendo lo mismo seguir haciendo lo que
me gustaba seguir emprendiendo y la
realidad es que hoy me encuentro
trabajando en una empresa muy desafiante
con muchos proyectos con la posibilidad
de hacer crecer el equipo en nuestra
zona también con las mismas tres
oficinas en la misma región con una
capacidad de crecimiento muy fuerte pero
siempre manteniendo el espíritu y la
esencia que siempre tuvimos en es
conceptual digamos el corazón y lo que
siempre pensamos hacer con nuestro
emprendimiento
ustedes
pensarán tal vez lo mismo que yo pensé
hay necesidad de haber construido esto y
después de llegar un punto y tomar otras
decisiones como que arrancar de cero es
que para mí esos momentos son cruciales
y son momentos donde uno vuelvan a hacer
o vuelve a reconvertirse o vuelve a
trascender vuelve a este es un base cero
es un sentimiento difícil de transmitir
pero para mí fue eso sí hoy volví a
trabajar en una empresa en un área
tecnología una relación de dependencia y
estoy feliz está bien
para mí ese decir adiós al
emprendimiento fue un decir adiós
con cierta nostalgia porque por supuesto
uno deja cosas importantes en la vida
pero en decir adiós para poder crecer
esta imagen que ven es de todo historia
y tres su momento final de la película
donde andy es el dueño de los juguetes
tiene que tomar una visión difícil sus
decisiones me voy a la universidad tengo
que crecer emprender hacer otra cosa y
tengo que abandonar lo que más quiero lo
que me acompañó toda la vida lo que
estuvo siempre los domingos que son mis
juguetes
tomo la decisión pero los juguetes los
dejo en manos de alguien que los puede
proteger que les da la contención y que
la tranquilidad andy digamos de que
puede tomar esa decisión es una lógica
linda que me vía la mente con la
película toy story y huesos las quería
compartir
antes se habla un poco de esto no no fue
coincidencia realmente no estaba
previsto no sabía la charla pero el
corazón y la razón y el cerebro
indudablemente tienen o tuvieron que ver
en mí en las decisiones que tomé
en la primera decisión de cambio fuerte
cuando armamos el emprendimiento y
decidí irme de la empresa el corazón
tuvo mayor relevancia que el cerebro que
la razón en ese momento porque porque si
hubiese puesto la razón por sobre el
corazón posiblemente no hubiese seguido
de la empresa porque estaba seguro tenía
mi familia estaba en mis estándares y en
zona de confort adecuados para seguir
trabajando de esa manera y seguir
haciendo más de lo mismo pero mi corazón
me decía tenés que cambiar tenés que
cambiar buscas otra cosa este nuestro
camino tienes que buscar otro desafío y
por eso para mí el corazón en ese
momento le ganó a la razón le ganó al
cerebro le ganó a la lógica
y en el otro caso y lo actual al decidir
vender la compañía fue al revés
el cerebro el plan el pensar
estratégicamente cuál era el próximo en
camino no solamente para mí y mi socio
sino para nuestro grupo fue más fuerte y
tuvo mayor relevancia el sentimiento por
el emprendimiento que el corazón si
realmente en el momento de tomar la
decisión nosotros poníamos en la balanza
el corazón fuertemente y todo lo que
sentíamos por ese emprendimiento que
habíamos armado de cero o simplemente no
hubiésemos tomado la decisión es muy
probable que nos hemos tomado la
decisión
realmente son decisiones fuertes digamos
en la vida y bueno a mí particularmente
esta comparación me hace mucho sentido
cuando cuando quiero contar básicamente
qué es lo que me pasó
como cierre todo este aprendizaje todas
estas etapas toda esta historia estos
hitos que fueron pasando en mi vida
no son perdidas para mí si son activos
son aprendizajes que tengo que llevo en
mi corazón que sigo mi cabeza es parte
de lo que me ha generado esta vida que
tengo y creo que con ese cambio con lo
que uno genera transforma transforma
realmente transforma vidas transforma la
vida de las personas
decisiones a veces que parecen mínimas
cuando uno las mira retrospectiva son
decisiones muy fuertes que viéndolas
habiendo pasado tiempo tienen una
generación tan positiva muy fuerte en el
equipo en la sociedad en lo que vemos
todos los días quien estamos llevando
una con responsabilidad cargo de
liderazgo o generación de
emprendimientos y de proyectos y de
equipos esa historia nada se pierde todo
se transforma gracias
[Aplausos]